as the Mosasaur stays in hiding it waits
for the Megalodon to get close enough
finally extracts since the megalodon's
body is far too big for the Mosasaur to
bite
the Mosasaur attacks one of the
Megalodon's fins and despite the
Megalodon being such a massive
intimidating creature the Mosasaur is
able to chew through it quite easily
that's because the Megalodon is made out
of soft tissue and cartilage the only
hard part of its body is its teeth
as the Mosasaur bites into the shark's
fin the Mosasaur might expect the
Megalodon to either Retreat or die but
since the Megalodon shark is so massive
it won't give up just yet
with the Mosasaur chomping on its fin
the Megalodon knows where the reptile is